c'est l'un des rendez vous préférés des
amateurs de rivière les olympiques de
l'alma difficile de croire qu'ici
dimanche dernier cette rivière paisible
s'est transformé en torrent alors un
groupe de randonneurs expérimentés
souhaite alerter la population sur les
dangers qui peuvent les guetter une crue
soudaine
comment vous pouvez la voir est-ce que
vous avez des éléments
si j'envoie des branchages ainsi de
branchages de freya je fais attention
même le temps aussi c'est des signes
avant-coureurs voilà d'une montée des
eaux soudaine autre danger les gorges
des rivières
quelques amateurs de sensations fortes
si et lancent régulièrement eu qu à une
peur bleue dimanche dernier quand un de
ses proches s'est retrouvé coincé par
une crue soudaine alors qu'il remontait
l'alma le danger c'est que c'est pas
génial et puisque l'on parle pour une
randonnée pédestre et on ne fait pas à
quel moment commence le canyoning arrivé
au canyon les gens se débrouillent comme
ils peuvent et sont habillées comme ils
peuvent et ne sont pas équipés pour des
accidents qui mobilise régulièrement les
forces de secours comme sur le chemin
qui mène à la cascade de didier l'accès
y est pourtant interdite à cause d'un
captage d'eau le sentier n'est pas
entretenu ce qui ne freine pas les
randonneurs très nombreux aujourd'hui
de quoi agacer le président du comité de
randonnée pédestre
on a les bleus quatre mois j'étais à 15
jours et allons religion se baignant
dans les noeuds d'accord il ya le carbet
énormément d'intervention de confier le
début d'année donc il a des conditions
assez davis est ce à dire que ce sont
des sauveteurs se mettre en danger ou
voile sur les gens parce qu'ils sont
obligés d 10 juillet les lycées ou
dessus de la gaffe cannes 2
tous ces végétaux les pompiers ont ainsi
dû intervenir six fois cette année rien
que sur ce site
et gare aux randonneurs imprudent les
frais de secours seront à votre charge
puisque le sentier est interdite